I think it's gonna be like the PG
version of like my favorite snacks
in small Texas says enlarged to show
texture it was brownies for ants neither
dog treats there's basically space food
that tastes like chemicals but like
decent chemicals a mixture between
delicious chocolate and paint does that
look like the inside of a brownie to you
this is a gateway to sadness and
ultimately under them
if this brownie was a celebrity it be
tongs or there's standard on the couch
for professing his love to Katie Holmes
even though we all know this like a
contract marriage
I love these oh thanks for the big dose
of nostalgia man this one's already
given me the farts it's just like what
happens to your balls after your own
shower for 40 if this is my person I'm
trying this it would be it's pretty
delicious it's just buttery baked cheesy
goodness okay well done food scientists
I would say maybe Brittany know what
it's not good for you but you know it's
gonna be delicious
and you know just kids love it it was
like Katy Perry's Super Bowl halftime
show where is the cream I don't like
when people change Oreos from their
natural form do we have anything like
gasoline to wash this down so I can get
this gross taste out of my mouth this
two Oreos is like that home alone
sequel that didn't have Macaulay Culkin
oh it's just like right she just put the
name on it but it's a completely
different
our first small pretty good right here
do a Keebler's never really liked my
thing like Keebler I love me some people
yeah I love actually my like D is very
money reasonable and certainly a cracker
with the time to chocolate this would be
a great laxative
I would eat these for dessert if I had
nine bags on if I take your cookies me
right just eat up a bit better wise you
know cookie I want 10 cookies I don't
want one cookie you could have been
making money or making changes but
instead you have pop and 10 cookies it's
like P Diddy and that it was really cool
when you were young and then now you
have the grown-up version and not as
cool as it used to be I have never seen
the ingredient list for anything require
like two columns there's a lot of
variety in it fine I'll say the way it
tastes it tastes like a cheese it it's
good I mean it doesn't taste like the
known for their colors or something
let's say seven five four and five yes
Adam Levine is this cheese it and then
all the other guys are probably really
talented musician
and they're like really good but you
don't recognize you know who they are I
personally like the people of America to
just eat food and stop worrying about it
just eat the food you see the food oh
yeah Americans really need to eat more
food and stop thinking about their ok
good message